these leaks from Donald Trump these
loose lips the spilling the beans of
Donald Trump is starting to have an
impact for American national security
and intelligence you're probably aware
by now that about two weeks ago Donald
Trump revealed highly classified
intelligence about Isis to the Russian
ambassador to the US and the Russian
Foreign Minister to the US in the Oval
Office one of those people the Russian
ambassador to the u.s. Sergei Kiss react
is a suspected Russian spy recruiter
okay not exactly someone that Donald
Trump should be bragging to about the
great Intel he gets the information was
about Isis plots involving laptops on
airplanes and the information we now
know by every reasonable estimate came
from Israeli intelligence Israel did not
give the United States permission to
share that information with Russia in
fact we have a White House official who
spoke with the Washington Post on record
as saying quote trump revealed more
information to the russian ambassador
then we have shared with our own allies
we also learned that this was the sort
of bragging that Donald Trump was doing
about the great Intel that he gets as
president of the United States as if
that would surprise anybody
so Trump has been widely criticized for
this CI former CIA director John Brennan
testified two days ago and said that
this this is something Trump should have
checked about first with intelligence
before revealing it to these Russian
diplomats many people have been
understandably worried that this
reckless blathering could negatively
impact our intelligence relationship
with Israel because they might say hey
you know what we really can't tell the
American stuff because Trump is just
going to spill it reports are now
starting to tell us that that is exactly
what is going on Israel is now starting
to change its Intelligence Sharing
protocols after Donald Trump's meeting
with the Russians here is Israel's
Defense Minister Avigdor Lieberman
speaking to an Israeli radio station
where he said quote I can confirm that
we did a spot repair what we had to
clarify with our friends in the United
States we did we did our checks Israel
is declining to
disclose what specific changes have been
made
Lieberman went on to say during this
army radio interview not everything
needs to be discussed in the media some
things need to be talked about in closed
rooms I will say right secrets about
intelligence getting out is exactly what
got us into this problem in the first
place and clearly Israel has had a
series of serious conversations with US
intelligence telling them that this is
possibly jeopardizing a you you could
have put someone at risk imagine that
you are an operative that has worked
your way into Isis under what undercover
pretext or or or clandestine pretext we
don't know and maybe only three four or
five people know about this plot and now
Trump says in the Oval Office that they
know about the plot you are potentially
endangering the life of an allied
intelligence operative well maybe he's
just playing five dimensional chess you
know there's an old quote about keeping
your friends close and your enemies
closer
yeah the only way to really do that is
to distance yourself from Israel in the
UK if you have the Russians over in the
Oval Office and tell them your secret
so you mentioned the UK let's dig into
that now this is not just happening with
Israel the BBC is now reporting that
British police are also not sharing
intelligence with the United States in
their investigation of the Manchester
bombing at an ariana grande concert
earlier this week it's not specifically
because of Trump leaks but because
photos appearing to show debris from the
attack appeared in The New York Times
after a leak and it also came after the
name of the bomber now known to us as
Salman Abedi was leaked to US media
hours after the attack and British prime
minister Theresa May said she would tell
Donald Trump at a NATO meeting that
shared intelligence quote must remain
secure I wonder how Donald will take
that scolding from Teresa may I assume
probably not too well but listen these
boneheaded moves have real consequences
and exactly as predicted the United
States is now going to suffer as a
result of that yeah and you know if this
happened every now and then and maybe he
was giving an hour-long interview and
some information accidentally slipped
out that would be one thing but the fact
that he's calling world
and bragging about the information that
he has and then the public at large
begins to know about it it's a tree
mother it's a whole other level and it
is truly unprecedented in this census
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show taga dab
the hosting specialists are underwriting
today's program today's episode of the
David Pakman show they offer a range of
affordable and flexible hosting packages
this includes dedicated server solutions
Virtual Private servers cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
over 70% of taga dad's business comes
from repeat orders and recommendations
from existing customers and this is
really a testament to the support that
is so important to them to provide to
their customers currently taga devs
average Trustpilot review rating is nine
point seven out of ten which by the way
puts them at excellent with more and
more people wanting to try moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dad is offering our viewers and
listeners a ten British Pound free
credit to all new customers signing up
you can take advantage of this offer by
going to signup tag adapt calm /td PS by
supporting them you'll be supporting us
as well